[Musica]
quando
sono venuti a chiedermi di partecipare
stasera a questo dibattito ho detto sì
poi mi sono chiesto perché ho detto sì
perché era empoli empoli per me è sempre
stato posto che mi ricordava due anni
che ho frequentato l'istituto tecnico
qui in via leonardo da vinci
poi mi sono trasferito a san miniato
come ho iniziato cioè una storia lunga
però stasera vorrei parlarvi momentino
più del presente di quello che mi
succede oggi in questo mio passaggio
praticamente sono nato nel 1945 quindi
dovevo parlare stasera a pensa a una
platea di di gente giovane quindi
praticamente era per me anche abbastanza
difficile prepararmi dire qualcosa
quindi ho detto massacrare la banalità
cosa voleva dire voleva dire
praticamente un passaggio da quella che
è stata diciamo la mia vita di cittadino
normale samminiatese figlio di contadini
arrivare un giorno a abitare a new york
frequentare un mondo quindi come dire
non mi rendevo conto non mi sono reso
conto di che cosa è successo in tutti
questi anni è stato come massacrare una
vita un mondo ritrovarmi praticamente al
centro dell'attenzione quando al centro
dell'attenzione non volevo mai e mai
esserci oggi non vedo più alla moda non
vedo cerco sempre di studiare cose nuove
di vedere dove mi sto ritrovando che
cosa voglio fare
perché anche a una certa età non si
smette mai di criticarci di vedere cosa
puoi dire che cosa puoi fare per questa
generazione di giovani sono passato
praticamente a vivere in una casa dove
non c'era neppure l'energia elettrica
dopo è arrivato il primo telefono
l'energia per tutto tutte le cose sono
diventate tutto normale tutto troppo
normale mi sono chiesto ad avere il
telefono sempre con me a lasciare il
telefono di sabato e la domenica perché
non mi serviva più questo praticamente
era come qualcosa che non andava bene
sono sempre stato appassionato di arte
per me l'arte era qualcosa di molto più
importante della moda
la moda era una cosa fu tilera mi è
servita praticamente per entrare per
farmi come dire costruire la mia vita la
mia esistenza
però il mondo del latte era quello che
mi aveva sempre appassionate ho girato
il mondo sempre non tanto per vedere la
gente ma poi per cercare di ritrovare me
stesso nel mondo dell'arte di oggi
cosa succede se è una persona di
quest'età quando deve superare un
periodo così burrascoso non dico
politicamente perché non mi interessa ma
un periodo in cui la tecnologia ogni
giorno praticamente ti presenta cose
nuove
tu hai a una certa età ti ritrovi a
studiare per poter affrontare il mondo
mi sono ritrovato stasera la prima volta
a pagare un parcheggio con la carta di
credito dice una banalità ma io mi sono
chiesto come mai non avevo soldi
spiccioli e quindi
e cercare praticamente di pagare con la
carta di credito era una cosa
semplicissima quando l'ho fatta ma prima
di farla
sono arrivato a 10 minuti in ritardo qui
proprio perché stavo lì a studiare
questa cosa cosa succede c'è una persona
di quest'età che vuole essere aggiornato
vuole essere vivere l'attualità e poi si
ritrova davanti diciamo ha dei problemi
così semplici così stupidi che però poi
dopo ti portano a volte anche una certa
una certa sofferenza
io penso che sia ci sia bisogno di
tornare un po indietro
io vorrei ritornare un po alle origini
mi ritrovavo proprio in questa settimana
nel terreno che osa miniato con una
grande sorpresa ho visto che c'era lo
stesso nido di formiche vi quando avevo
15 anni cioè le formiche tutte in fila
che facendo sempre lo stesso lavoro la
stessa cosa e io dico ma guarda loro
vivevano una vita normale serena
tranquilla come mai io ho dovuto correre
dare fare per poi ritrovarmi dopo 60
anni ad e vedere la stessa cosa
penso che questa questo viaggio cioè
dalla natura alla tecnologia al mondo
che fa pensare fa pensare molto
e tu dici come puoi fare oggi per
superare per ridere perché tutte questo
tutto questo mondo tecnologico sta
fermando anzi io che vivo anche a new
york sono tutti i giorni mi trovo di
fronte a dovere per studiare per poter
superare per poter per potere
dire ok anche questo l'hai fatta anche
questo per una cosa normale tutto è
normale quando l'hai fatto la prima
volta la seconda volta la terza volta
però oggi tutto viene studiato pensando
a un mondo di giovani agente di o sette
nipoti che a 34 anni 5 anni hanno tutti
il suo telefonino tecnologico però sanno
tutto
tante accendere praticamente un
televisore può diventare problematico
non viene più affrontato il problema che
con l'età avanzata
tutta questa tecnologia che può anche
portare a soffrire su certe cose io dico
che sarebbe anche il caso di fermarci a
tenere presente cioè considerare anche
un mondo di persone che non sono più
giovani che magari non hanno dei
problemi però ci sono anche più persone
che non hanno disabilità max col passare
del tempo possano trovarsi in difficoltà
certo la tecnologia che può aiutare io
piazzo sul mio telefonino quando mi devo
alzare se devo prendere una pillola via
bertano cioè tutto è molto più semplici
ma questo cosa ti fa ti fa ti porta a
dover piu pensare invece sarebbe meglio
educare la tua testa a pensare ancora a
non demandare certe problematiche alla
alla tecnologia questo
certamente non viene preso in
considerazione perché quando uno vede
una persona come me che ci ha 72 anni
pensa a 9 giovane quello fa questo fa
quell'altro cioè invece le difficoltà
anche nel mio caso ci sono io sono una
persona molto fortunata nella vita
perché con il mio lavoro mi ha permesso
di non avere problemi finanziari di
vivere dove volevo vivere avere a
disposizione tutto quello che volevo
però in fondo di tutte queste cose che
non ho mai voluto niente ho cercato
praticamente di non farmi preferire in
un contesto di personaggio pubblico del
bel personaggio pubblico non esisteva
alcune volte ho dovuto farlo quando il
periodo della mia vita non facendo solo
calze ero inserito in un mondo della
moda io ho sfilato a milano tre anni tre
anni a parigi facendo diciamo una
collezione completa di un abbigliamento
molto particolare che poi dopo un certo
momento ho deciso di lasciare perché non
era quello che la mia vita mi avrebbe
dato soddisfazioni la soddisfazione che
poteva venire a me veniva da qualcosa
che non che ho trovato in un'età
avanzata riuscire voler trasformare il
mondo tessile di un prodotto che facevo
per elevarlo a inserirlo in un contesto
matematico per farla diventare un'opera
d'arte
questo ha richiesto studio
ha chiesto uno sforzo mentale è
veramente molto molto forte
e poi mi ha aiutato molto libere in un
contesto come new york molto avanzato e
trovare una sistemazione a quella che
era la mia visione dell'arte e farla mia
tutti gli artisti cercano di fare suo un
mondo però non sai mai se quello che fai
te è stato già fatto e valido puoi avere
delle contestazioni può avere degli
applausi e stato veramente molto molto
complicato e molto molto rischioso di
ottenuto questa mia passione che ora è
diventato anche la mia vita il mio
lavoro adesso nel mondo dell'arte mi ha
permesso di ritornare indietro nel tempo
il mio confronto
oggi ho visto l'ho superato perché oggi
io mi confronto con la mia arte con
ragazzi di 18 20 25 anni e non ho paura
ho paura perché so che posso dire
qualcosa di nuovo che quello che sto
facendo è una cosa che altri non hanno
fatto che prosegue gli studi di artisti
molto ma molto grandi che però non ho
copiato ho fatto mio una successione di
cose però non ho preso niente
oggi sono come dire ha pagato di quello
che ho fatto di quello che sto facendo e
quindi mi sono trovato un uomo libero
faccio le cose importanti il viaggio il
mondo e poi mi ritrovo a san miniato del
potere accogliere lug quello che ho
fatto stamani mattina e sono felice e
superato tanti momenti belli tanti
momenti brutti però il mondo è fatto di
sacrifici perché tu se non fai sacrifici
poi non puoi apprezzare neppure i
momenti più come dire più facili dietro
a una cosa brutta c'è sempre una cosa
molto bella
qualcuno di voi forse mi conosce di nome
essendo samminiatese può anche aver
seguito però io non sono non sono mai
stato un personaggio pubblico come
dicevo prima sa miniato tutti conoscono
il mio nome ma magari non sanno nemmeno
chi sono perché io passo di macchina e
vado a casa firenze ho abitato in un
palazzo per tanti anni nessuno sapeva
che abitavo io all'ultimo piano
questo succede in italia specie quando
sono arrivato a new york
io sono entrato nella mia prima casa mi
aveva mi è arrivato il i condomini del
piano avevano preparato un rinfresco di
benvenuto
io sono rimasto molto sorpreso perché ho
detto ma beh per me forse un errore
come mai no perché la gente si informa
di quello che sei ma vogliono sapere chi
è chi è che viene abitare vicino a loro
no per chiedere qualcosa ma perché per
fare comunità
quello che praticamente oggi non succede
più nelle nostre città succede nelle
grandi grandi città e non succede
in una città come firenze in cui cioè ti
devi sempre sempre sempre chiedere a te
stesso non domandare niente agli altri
non scomodare nessuno e allora mi sto
domandando perché giro perché faccio
tutto questo cioè andare a trovare
qualcosa di diverso quando le cose più
importanti ce l'hai tutte vicino a te
quindi ho detto massacrare la banalità
la parità delle cose cercare di
dimostrare più niente di quello che non
sei
perché ormai non mi interessa più a
nessuno
[Applauso]